some Secrets should remain
buried I am sorry don't hate me I I had
car stuff and then I I couldn't find my
keys and you don't get to just blow in
here acting like you care all of a
sudden I'm not
acting Ma's dead read the well
please your mother rarely spoke of her
childhood she never spoke of it and she
always dodged our questions well in the
end she decided to talk
I had promised myself I would take all
of this with me to my grave I didn't
want to burden you with the weight of it
but I must confess Elanor is not my real
name ki
wait I had to protect you from the life
I was forced to
have I have a way that you can erase all
your debts my daughter is only 16
no better age for a
wife in order to ensure my
safety someone would have to
[Music]
die none of this makes sense I mean did
Dad know any of this with the stress of
all these secrets Weighing on her she
must have felt so alone for the rest of
my life I'm going to keep looking over
my shoulder what are you running
from betrayal is a powerful thing but
love brings the light that will guide
you out of your darkest moments how many
more secrets was my
[Music]
keeping she has a story our story we
just have to keep listening some secrets
are best left buried here's the past
may it not blow up our
[Music]
present this is your story
too